one of the things you tweeted recently
that i found really fascinating is uh
you basically were saying look if i was
to start a ddc brand today
i would go after product first then i'd
go for distribution and then i would
focus on brand
um when people think of d to c i think
this goes back to the conversation
around like they have a specific type of
company in their mind right so maybe
like a casper
or whatever it is uh and they think of
like really
powerful brands or well-known brands uh
and then maybe it's something about
uh the product and then the distribution
and so in my head like that's kind of
the starting point for some people when
they hear d2c
another kind of data point on this is uh
yc is famous for saying you know first
time founders focus on product
second time founders focus on
distribution uh and so when i saw kind
of your order
um in terms of what you would focus on
it would surprise me a little bit maybe
talk through like why
product and distribution and then brand
uh kind of if you were to build a dc
company today
yeah listen i think that was a very
unique tweet for me i wouldn't normally
say something like that
but that was in response to that
bloomberg
uh blending report i don't know if you
saw that it was really
really interesting um i forgot what was
the report
he was essentially it was a great
opinion piece i forgot the gentleman's
name but he was essentially writing that
um
a lot of these direct consumer brands
seem sort of idyllic
and identical in their approach to
messaging their approach to
their marks their actual physical marks
and all that stuff
and uh a lot of that is the result of
the what i call the d2c industrial
complex
you know there's probably 10 or 15
agencies that get paid
really really well to produce uh
images and brands and messagings and a
narrative around the founders and why
they started the company and everything
like that and so
you're seeing the same adjectives and
the same sort of positioning
for every single brand and a lot of it
a lot of it is being sort of called out
because
not only are a lot of these brands doing
that um
and listen there are a few there are a
few exceptions in that article
uh i would like to cite that like the
sills included in that article whereas
she bootstrapped for the first five
years
she probably didn't have any business
being in that article to be fair but
the larger point was there is sort of a
homogeny about all of it and
couple that with the fact that there
have been so few exits
and so little liquidity outside of you
know a handful of founders
taking 10 million off the table here and
there which i
definitely disagree with um
and what you have is sort of a
frustration within the industry
the antidote to that uh the antidote to
that is essentially
building a product that people actually
like right
and so when i was tweeting that i was
talking about a lot of the brands that
actually
did achieve liquidity
events brands that did grow on profit
and cash flow
versus raising the five million dollars
first coming up with
the brand and the message then rolling
out the product and hoping for the best
there are a number of those companies
and so i cited
you know jay's ice creams in columbus
ohio there's siete foods in
in austin san antonio i believe uh
there's bulletproof
you know there's going back a little bit
further there's uh
gt dave and synergy right you know these
are
companies that are on the way to billion
dollar status and
they did it way differently than the
vast majority of direct direct to
consumer brands today
typically do it and they're seeing more
success so you have to ask yourselves
why and
my short answer is that they focused on
building a great product first
and getting those people to actually
like it the product developed the
audience
in ways yeah it's really really
interesting because uh
you know we're talking about d2c type
companies right now but we've seen this
uh with other companies as well so
whether it's the nikola
uh kind of car company right or it's the
quibbes
of the world who kind of go out they
raise tons of money and i think that you
know people who have been around a while
especially
from a venture capital perspective uh
red flag number one is you raise way too
much money and you don't even have a
product yet right
red flag number two is like you don't
have any of the venture capital firms
actually invested so they kind of all
passed and you went elsewhere for
capital
um and i think that like every once in a
while we have to almost have these to
remind everyone
of this focus on like the ultimate goal
here is to find that product market fit
uh it's not to raise as much capital as
possible um so it's interesting that you
know even though
you see it in the d2c space and it kind
of feels like this like homogeneous type
thing the mechanism is still happening
elsewhere as well right it's almost like
a sign of the times to some degree it
feels like
oh for sure i mean i think that you
raised a few interesting points
obviously uh with nicola it's
uh that's a great example of not having
anything to show for
a lot of money invested but you know in
a much lesser sense
there are no brands that are as
egregious nearly as egregious as what
that company's done
but there are a lot of brands that don't
really have a path to exit optionality
because they've raised a lot of money
relative to their potential market cap
and
they they are not private equity fodder
anymore because of that
because of that cap table situation um
and
they will probably not be able to reach
sort of
um exit velocity because
they need paid marketing or whatever
mechanism is out there to to really sort
of gain a lot of traction within the
industry
it's just a really weird dance and i
think the only way to beat that dance
is to have a product that can put up
numbers um
what i would say anywhere between one to
three million in the first five years
and annual revenue profitably
before they're really taking on growth
capital if that's sort of the dna of the
company i think that company
actually has a better shot of becoming a
billion dollar brand than somebody
coming out of the gates raising 20 to 50
million
yeah and talk a little bit about how
you're seeing founders uh
navigate to that point right so when
somebody here's kind of a million to
three million dollars there's certain
businesses where the
um capital needed to to start is very
low right literally just if you can
build
a piece of software then you're off to
the races uh some of these businesses
though there's physical products
involved there's some capital intensive
nature and so how do you see founders
kind of getting off the ground
to the point where it may make sense to
actually go out and raise kind of these
larger rounds
yeah listen i i know that nothing
happens in a vacuum
right i mean if you look at mizzen we
definitely raised the 250 000
friends and family round we we would
still consider ourselves bootstrappers
in ways because
you know we didn't pay ourselves for the
first two and a half years and trust me
was really painful
um but uh we we tried to build a
strategy around not needing to raise
more money
and we did and because we built a
strategy around
trying to not raise more money we were
probably more capable of raising money
in a reasonable fashion that put the
company in a decent long-term position
um i would say that uh listen
i think that for a lot of founders
especially coastal ones raising money is
pretty easy relative to the industry
and direct to consumer was hot
it's fallen off but it's come it's
coming back as e-commerce penetration
continues to rise and so
it's going to continue to be easier for
la
new york san francisco boss and so on
and so forth to
to raise that 3 million seed or precede
even
you know and i just don't think that
that's the
the route even if you are in a capital
intensive business
um try to do it without the
institutional capital try to do it you
know
with people that know you know you well
and believe in your vision
obviously not everyone has that rolodex
i i trust me i speak from experience
um we didn't have that rolodex the very
beginning it was very hard for us but
it can be done and you know for
reference
that entire 250 000 capital expenditure
was focused on buying our first run
of first generation shirts from mizzen
which
you know sorry kevin i mean i can think
i think you can say this now because we
can look back on it fondly but
the first generation of shirts they
weren't great
so selling them was pretty difficult but
we found a way to do it